5 25 on your monday morning heads up on
that additional headache in the big
squeeze may change your travel plans the
department of transportation has shut
down the exit ramp to get off the south
95 515 at eastern it is kind of a big
deal so i hope this heads up helps you
now there is some signage but if you
miss it and you forget to get off at las
vegas boulevard it's probably going to
be a little bit crowded there you'll
have to continue on to charleston which
also may jam up now during this closure
they're adding an extra lane to the exit
ramp so when it opens back up near the
end of may it shouldn't be backing up to
the freeway at rush hour so even if the
95 515 is not your regular freeway
checking out the ndot website or signing
up for alerts probably a good idea we've
got those links in the online version of
this story when you go to
eightnewsnow.com click traffic then
driving you crazy buckle up drive
carefully please put down that phone
something driving you crazy email me
traffic8newsnow.com